well hello and welcome to my home my  house is your house please come in  protective so this is my house my studio  my dining room go more this is where I  eat sleep and work Rocky movie when I  yeah I live in a studio not a normal  apartment this is where I sleep the sofa  folds out into a bed and it's pretty  comfortable to the rest of the space is  my studio for work  portfolio this is oil paint on thin  brass leaf it's applied in many layers I  think it's a good piece of work  entonces esto es para this is a spinning  wheel a friend of mine from Pakistan  gave it to me exam bahador he didn't  have room for it in this apartment I  like it and I enjoy being surrounded by  beautiful things  this one picking of it I want it I  carved this small dragon out of a bone I  used to have dogs and they were always  bringing me bones like this  why don't we thanks for visiting I have  to make some dinner for a friend now so  I'll say goodbye safe travels bye-bye a  federal